now while most of us
here overnight were sleeping a huge part
of the las vegas economy
came to a screeching halt everything
from the las vegas strip
to restaurants even salons are all
closing at the governor's request
that is from one year ago today the
bright lights of the las vegas strip
were dimmed alex
wow can't believe that was a year ago
hotels you'll remember they all went
dark because of course they were shut
down
instead they lit up those messages of
hope last march it was governor steve
systella who ordered all non-essential
businesses in nevada to close to slow
the spread of the coronavirus but now
las vegas is coming back to life bianca
holman live on the strip this morning
with a look back and some positive signs
now for the future good morning bianca
hey good morning john good morning alex
so things look a lot different out here
on the las vegas strip
besides having to wear a mask and
socially distance it looks like tourism
is springing back to life out here now
here goes a look back at some of that
video from a year ago
march 2020 you can see that the bellagio
it was boarded up
metro police blocked the entrance to the
wind and other resorts
and some casinos they didn't have locks
on the doors and so they had to
improvise when it came to a shutting
down
it was supposed to be a 30-day closure
but it was nearly three months before
resorts were allowed to reopen
june 4th we lost so many events over the
past year but there's hope
on the horizon this is expected to be
the busiest weekend
in a year casinos restaurants and other
businesses are allowed to be open at 50
capacity nearly 40 shows have reopened
and spring break the ncaa tournament
basketball tournament that's all
happening
this coming weekend so that's going to
draw big crowds and tourists and sports
bettors so
things are looking pretty good room
rates and occupancy rates are also on
the rise
now despite all of these positive things
that are happening analysts do predict
that it's going to take about 18 months
to three years
for us to reach those pre-pandemic
levels reporting live from the las vegas
strip bianca coleman 8 news now